طيب خلينا نروح الى جولتنا الاخباريه
الثانيه مع مراسلتنا ندى حجازي من مصر
واول المواضيع بيقولوا الاسماك ممنوعه في
مصر يعني ما فيش بلطي خلاص يا ندى
صباح الخير لا مش كل الاسماك الحمد لله مع
ان انا ما بحبش السمك فده يعني مصلحه ما
بتحبيش السمك يا الله طيب
بتحب الجمبري يلا خلينا نلاقي
طيب ايه حكايه السمك محافظه البحر الاحمر
اصدرت قرار بمنع صيد السمك وتداوله في
المحال والمطاعم السمك القاتن في البحر
الاحمر بس وده طبعا بسبب ان كان فيه
الفتره اللي فاتت للاسماك فده ادى لاختلال
في التوازن البيئي وكمان تحميل على الشعب
المرجانيه فالقرار ده مدته شهرين من شهر
مايو لشهر اغسطس مش هيكون فيه اي صيد لاي
نوع من انواع الاسماك اللي موجوده في
البحر الاحمر مش هيكون في مراكب همم
بتسيير في البحر بالليل خالص ولا بتبات في
البحر وهيتم تعويض الصيادين عن الشهرين
اللي مش هيشتغلوا فيهم دول بمبلغ يقدر ب
4000 جنيه عن كل شهر علشان يقدروا ان هم
يتحملوا يعني توابع ندى في موضوع اخر يعني
على ما يبدو خبر صادم بيتحدث عن وفاه شقيق
البلوجر المصريه الشهيره شريهان يوسف شو
تفاصيل شو القصه
للاسف حقيقي يعني دي حاجه للاسف كارثيه
لانه ال ااا الشعريه سريعه التحضير زي
دلوقتي بقت
وجبه اساسيه عند اطفال كتير جدا في
المدارس في عمر الشاب اللي توفى هو
بالمناسبه عنده 17 سنه دخل في تحدي مع حد
من صحابه التحدي ده كان قائم على انه مين
هيقدر ياكل اكبر كم او قدر من النودلز
سريعه التحضير الكوريه الحره مش العاديه
فطبعا اكلها بكميه كبيره جدا عشان يكسب
التحدي وده سبب له فشل في الكلى وسبب له
مشكله في المراره قعدوا يحاولوا ان هم
يسعفوه لمده خمس ايام كاملين ما قدروش
وللاسف توفى طيب ما ده لا هنالك جمل مستمر
حول السبب الحقيقي كما يقال في التفاصيل
اذن شكرا لك ندى وبالتحديات كثرت حقيقه
حتى منها القرفه منها امور ربما الضرب على
الراس وغيره وبالتالي للاسف بسبب هيك
تحديات للاسف
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات